throughout this course we've seen that
the modern engineering enterprise is
characterized
by the design and construction of
technologies
that perform important functions while
operating as efficiently as possible
yet one of america's most famous
engineers earned great notoriety by
doing exactly the opposite
designing excessively complex
inefficient devices
that accomplished laughably simple or
even useless tasks
his name was rube goldberg
reuben garrett lucius goldberg lived
from 1883 to 1970.
he earned an engineering degree from the
university of california at berkeley in
1904
and practiced engineering briefly before
changing course and pursuing what would
become a highly successful career
as a cartoonist and author the cartoons
that have earned him
lasting fame depict farcical inventions
that perform simple tasks
by fantastically complicated means
here's a typical example rube goldberg's
self-operating napkin which self
operates as follows
as the diner raises the spoon to his
mouth
this string pulls downward on the handle
of a ladle
throwing this cracker past a hungry
parrot
which flies from its perch to retrieve
the cracker
thereby causing the perch to tilt
tipping this bowl of seeds
into the adjacent bucket the bucket's
added weight pulls a
cord which activates a cigarette lighter
igniting the fuse of a skyrocket
when the rocket launches the attached
sickle cuts this string
which releases the clock pendulum to
which a napkin has been attached
as the pendulum oscillates back and
forth the napkin wipes the diner's mouth
and in case you hadn't noticed this
wonderfully ridiculous machine is
configured as a hat
which enhances his portability while
also making a rather dramatic fashion
statement
this is rube goldberg at his finest
now goldberg created these inventions
to entertain us and certainly not to
communicate the ethic of engineering
efficiency
yet they do have potential learning
value
in at least three respects first
goldberg's inventions illustrate the
integrative
nature of modern engineering
demonstrating how
a wide variety of mechanical and
biomechanical subsystems
can be integrated to accomplish a single
function
second they illustrate the creative
dimension of engineering
demonstrating quite vividly that there's
always more than one valid approach to
solving a technological problem
and most importantly from the
perspective of this course
rube goldberg's inventions provide us
with a wonderful opportunity to review
key concepts from earlier lectures
while also testing our newly acquired
diy engineering know-how
seriously is it just me or does the
self-operating napkin
look like a graphical course syllabus
for diy engineering
check it out it's all here a structural
frame
a parabolic cable a catapult
projectile motion an aeronautical system
a lever subjected to torque application
of load with a bucket full of stuff
potential and kinetic energy pulleys
friction
rocketry impulse momentum pendulum
motion
and we may safely infer an elaborate
gear train inside the clock
you know if rube goldberg did such an
effective job of summarizing our course
without even trying
how well might we be able to do it if we
really put our minds to it
my friends welcome to diy engineering
project number 17
which is also your final exam the design
requirement
is to design build and test a machine in
the spirit of rube goldberg
that will perform a function most of us
do many times a day
click the button of a computer mouse
now why use a mouse click as the purpose
of our machine
well first i hope to communicate that
rube goldberg's fanciful inventions can
be just as relevant and just as much fun
today
as they were back in an era when the
pendulum clock was cutting edge
information technology
but there's a more important reason
which i'll share with you later in this
lecture
for now back to the design requirements
to fulfill its purpose as a course
review our machine must incorporate the
following
20 technological elements presented here
in their order of appearance in our
previous lectures
a linear spring braced frame
lever beam suspension bridge
sail lighter than air object
aerodynamic lift aerodynamic stability
a propeller electric circuit torsion
spring
counterweight hydraulic system bell
crank
hydro power gear train pendulum
electric motor and pulley and
not only must all of these elements be
included in the design
they must actually contribute to the
machine's ultimate purpose
thus for example we can't just mount a
sail on a beam and claim we've met these
two requirements
both of these elements must actually
function as a sail
and as a beam such that the mouse won't
get clicked
unless they work properly and contribute
their respective functions to the
overall operation of the machine
furthermore the machine must be set in
motion by a single human action
once it's running we're not allowed to
help it along and finally
in the spirit of unconstrained
creativity that lies at the heart of
rube goldberg's inventions
the only constraints we'll specify are
that the machine must actually be
buildable
and it must be operated safely indoors
now admittedly
these constraints will probably rule out
design alternatives involving the use of
parrots and skyrockets
but they also keep me out of trouble
with the great courses management
in my view this is a compromise worth
making
okay having specified our design
requirements and constraints
let's get to work if you're interested
in doing this project on your own
either as a final exam or just for fun
now is the time to do it
i can't overemphasize this point this
project
is an exercise in creative design it has
no right or wrong answers
but the creative process can easily be
compromised by
preconceived notions of what the right
answer might be
in a moment i'll be guiding you through
my own design for this project
if you just want to follow along that's
great but if you want to actually
experience the creative design process
don't allow yourself to be influenced by
my solution
hit the pause button pull out a pad of
paper and start sketching your ideas
and yes you will need a sketch pad
you know throughout this course i've
attempted to demonstrate that sketching
by hand is essential to the creative
process of engineering design
in this era of high-tech computer-based
design tools
it's easy to overlook the value of an
old-fashioned pencil and pad
or an old-fashioned whiteboard in giving
shape to ideas
but please don't overlook them as we've
seen throughout this course
computer-based tools are immensely
valuable as well
but their value is typically realized
later in the design process
when reasonably well-formed ideas must
be translated into an actual design
another tool we'll need for this
particular project is a checklist like
this one
which will help us keep track of our
progress in incorporating the 20 design
elements specified in our project
requirements we'll be returning to this
list often
now how shall we begin i suggest
that this problem is way too complicated
to solve
all at once so let's proceed by
considering the 20 design elements
individually or in small logically
related clusters
for each of these we'll ask three
questions how can we implement
this element such that it performs a
well-defined action that has
some potential to contribute to our
machine's ultimate purpose
then what input is required to initiate
this action
and finally what output will this action
produce
then once we've sketched these elements
in isolation
we'll attempt to pull them together into
an integrated hole
a sort of chain of events beginning with
a single human input
with the output of each action then
serving as input to the next
and with the final output fulfilling the
machine's ultimate purpose
so with this general methodology in mind
i suggest that we now begin
at the end with the final link in this
chain of events
the mouse click and what better way for
our machine to click a mouse
than to mimic the motion of a human
index finger
from our list of design elements it
seems that the bell crank is best suited
to this purpose
as it will allow us to convert a
horizontal pull
into a vertical push using the relative
lengths of the bell crank's two arms to
control both the applied force
and the range of motion but a proper
mouse click involves both a downward
push and a release
how can we get the bell crank to return
to its original position after each push
huh this looks like a job for a torsion
spring
let's try the common type of torsion
spring configuration that's used in
clothes pins and mouse traps
a simple wire coil with a perpendicular
leg on each end
okay we've now used two design elements
the bell crank and torsion spring
and combined them into a sub-assembly
which we'll call the mouse
clicker and here's my computer model
which translates this sketch into a
buildable device
and can be used to examine its functions
more closely
the output of the mouse clicker is
obvious but what input will it require
well to operate properly the lower end
of the bell crank must receive a
moderate horizontal pulling force
applied through a distance of perhaps a
quarter to a half an inch
but only for a short period of time then
this force must decrease to near
zero so the torsion spring can return
the bell crank to its original position
thus releasing the mouse button okay
that's
two down and 18 more design elements to
go
after getting rid of my first sketch we
can now focus on the hydraulic system
which seems like a particularly
challenging element to incorporate into
this design
our tried and true approach is to use a
pair of water-filled
plastic syringes which will actually
serve as the actuator and hydraulic ram
as they did in our lecture about
hydraulic machinery this system will
provide an effective means of
transmitting force from the actuator to
the ram through a plastic tube
of any length we choose our challenge is
that the
input to this system must be a
relatively large steady force
applied to the actuator how might we
generate such a force within our machine
well suppose we add a lever like this
with a heavy
counterweight fixed to its short end the
lever is configured such that
after it rotates through 90 degrees the
counterweight will come to rest
on the plunger of the first syringe thus
applying the steady force required to
actuate the hydraulic system
the lever's long arm is provided so that
a trigger placed at its tip can hold the
arm in its initial position with minimal
force
thus the force required to release this
trigger will also be small
well by now you've probably noticed that
this combination of lever
and counterweight bears a very strong
resemblance to our trebuchet
this similarity suggests that a modified
version of our trebuchet
trigger will work here too we'll
configure this trigger
such that it can be released by a small
downward force
perhaps a falling object striking its
horizontal arm
we've now used three more design
elements the lever
counterweight and hydraulic system and
combine them into another sub assembly
which can be activated by a small
downward force on the trebuchet
trigger and which produces as output the
steady force
and linear motion of the hydraulic ram
next let's turn
to another challenging design element
hydro power
now clearly we'll want to use an
elevated water reservoir
serving as a source of potential energy
to power the water jet
as we did in our water turbine project
and because the reservoir must be
elevated
we can support it with a braced frame
tower and thus
check off another design element but how
can we switch on the water jet
well in the interest of simplicity we
can use a simple stopper to control the
flow from the outlet tube as we did in
our turbine project
but how will we generate the substantial
force required to pull the stopper out
of the tube
recognizing that a stretched spring can
develop a substantial internal force
and a lever can magnify a force let's
try combining a linear spring
and a lever to meet this need now
initially we'll hold the system in
position with a thin
wire attached to a fixed support
when the wire is cut the stretched
spring will pull the stopper from the
outlet tube
and it will also pull the lever through
a full 90 degrees of rotation
thus moving the stopper clear of the
water jet so it won't interfere with the
jet's operation
okay this is another nicely packaged
sub-assembly
which incorporates water power a braced
frame
a linear spring and another lever and
here's the corresponding computer model
which illustrates the required input
cutting the wire that holds the
spring-loaded lever in position
and the output a force applied by the
water jet
most likely to a vertical surface
positioned immediately in front of the
jet
next how shall we incorporate a design
element
that demonstrates aerodynamic stability
and we know a lot about achieving
stability in the design of a rocket
though obviously we won't be able to
ignite a rocket engine here in the
studio
wait i have an idea suppose that we hung
a small model rocket from a string
to create a pendulum we could arrange
this sub-assembly such that
if the rocket is stable it will hit a
target of some sort at the extreme
opposite end of the pendulum swing but
if it's unstable it will turn
sideways and miss the target
to make this concept work we'll need a
release mechanism for the rocket
let's try a simple retainer pin that
passes through a wooden block
and engages with a wire eye fixed to the
back of the rocket
ok we can now check off the pendulum and
aerodynamic stability
as input the resulting sub-assembly will
require a downward pull
on this retainer pin to release the
rocket
and its output will be a small force
really little more than a nudge
delivered by the rocket to its target
next it seems quite obvious that we
should use an electric motor
as part of an electric circuit and
furthermore we could use this motor to
spin a propeller
and the resulting air stream might be
directed at a sail
moreover if we position the sail at an
appropriate angle of attack
it will generate aerodynamic lift
let's try putting all these elements
together with a sketch
now viewed from above here's our motor
propeller and electric circuit
now suppose we mounted the sail on a
pivoting boom
such that the sail's aerodynamic lift
force
caused the boom to rotate this rotation
would eventually move the sail out of
the airstream
at which point both the lift force and
the motion would stop
but wait isn't this just what we need to
activate our mouse clicker
a force that's applied for a short
period of time and then stops
there seems to be great potential here
but to make this work we'll need to
translate the rotational motion of the
boom
into a linear pull on the mouse clicker
and we'll need to do it in a way that
provides a high degree of control
over both the magnitude of the pulling
force and the distance through which
it's applied
ah fortunately we can achieve the
required degree of control
and check off another design element by
adding a gear train
right here at the pivot point of the
boom the larger gear will be fixed
directly to the boom on which the sail
is mounted
and on the smaller gear you can mount a
cord
that will be used to activate the mouse
clicker assuming that this cord will
need to be
redirected along its route from the gear
train to the mouse clicker
we can add a pulley to this sub-assembly
as well
now let's use a computer model to
examine how this system will actually
work
its input must be the closing of the
electrical circuit to start the motor
now with the propeller spinning the boom
will rotate through 45 degrees
from its initial position to the point
at which the sail moves beyond the
airstream
and stops developing lift the larger of
our two gears will rotate along with the
boom
and because we want the smaller gear to
rotate through 180 degrees
as the larger one rotates through 45
degrees
we'll use a gear ratio of one to four
the cord that activates the mouse
clicker is mounted one half inch from
the center of the smaller gear
as shown here thus as this gear rotates
through 180 degrees
it'll first pull the cord a half inch to
click the mouse
and then after the 180 degree rotation
is complete
there will be no more force on the sail
and therefore no tension in the cord
so the mouse click will be released and
at its peak
the magnitude of this pulling force will
be roughly 10 times
larger than the aerodynamic force
applied to the sail
well this is a very important
sub-assembly
not only because it will use seven of
our design elements
the motor electric circuit propeller
sail aerodynamic lift gear train and
pulley
but also because it has addressed the
critical issue of how to activate the
mouse clicker
okay at this point there are only three
unused design elements remaining in our
list
we'll certainly be able to use the beam
and suspension bridge to provide
structural support to some of the other
design elements
but the lighter than air object presents
another significant
challenge we can easily include this
element in our machine by using a
helium-filled balloon
but what will it actually do the net
buoyant force developed by a standard
size helium balloon is only about 1 10
of an ounce
we can't possibly use such a small force
to pull a trigger
or throw a switch ah
but we could use it to complete our
electrical circuit
in a more creative way let's call this
a balloon switch we'll start
with a wooden platform and drill a 1 8
inch hole
through it next we'll glue two copper
tabs to the bottom
aligned with a hole like this but not
touching each other
and we'll attach the wires of our
electric circuit to these tabs
with a pair of screws we'll tie our
helium balloon
to a piece of thread that runs down
through the hole
and is looped over a hook below on this
thread
below the platform we'll attach a thin
copper disk about one half
inch in diameter now when the thread is
released
the balloon will float upward and the
copper disk will span from one copper
tab to the other
closing the circuit
okay we're getting close we now have six
sub-assemblies that need to be
interconnected to create a single
machine
which must also incorporate a beam and a
suspension bridge
let's try using this project integration
matrix as a tool to facilitate this
final stage of design concept
development
for convenience we'll designate the six
sub-assemblies as
a through f sub-assembly a is the mouse
clicker
which requires a pull and release on its
bell crank as
input sub assembly b includes the
counterweighted lever and hydraulic
system
activated by a downward force applied to
our trebuchet trigger
and producing the force and linear
motion of a hydraulic ram as its output
sub assembly c is our hydropower system
which requires the cutting of a wire
as input and produces the water jet's
force as
output sub-assembly d is our rocket
pendulum
set in motion by a downward tug on its
release mechanism
and producing as output a small nudge at
the opposite end of the pendulum's arc
sub-assembly e is the motor propeller
sail
gear train pulley system that will
provide the pull
and release required to activate the
mouse clicker
its required input is the closing of the
motor's electric circuit
and sub-assembly f is our balloon switch
which will close the circuit
several connections between these
sub-assemblies have already been defined
the output of subassembly e will
activate the mouse clicker
and the output of f the balloon switch
will close the electrical circuit as
input to e
there are several ways we might assemble
the remaining pieces
but one that seems particularly simple
is to use the thrust of the hydraulic
ram
at subassembly b to release the balloon
string
simply by pushing it off of its hook
and because the rocket pendulum can only
deliver a nudge let's use it to knock a
golf ball
off of an elevated tee into a trough
which will carry the ball across a
horizontal span thus fulfilling our
requirement for a beam
and then drop the ball onto the
trebuchet trigger
now there's only one output left so
logically the water jet's force must
somehow trigger the rocket pendulum
and the human action that sets the
machine in motion must be the triggering
of the water jet
so how can we use the water jet to
provide the downward tug that will
trigger the rocket pendulum
ah let's build a small
wheeled cart that incorporates a double
bucket just like a pelton wheel
on its vertical surface facing the water
jet we'll connect this car to the rocket
trigger with a string
and we'll place the cart on a sort of a
bridge to nowhere
such that as the water jet propels it
off the precipice
the falling cart will activate the
rocket release mechanism
moreover this bridge to nowhere looks
like a fine opportunity to integrate a
suspension bridge into our overall
design concept
we'll use the cable to support not only
the roadway of the bridge to nowhere but
the waterjet outlet tube as well
well we've now successfully used all 20
of the required design elements
and we've created computer models of the
six major sub-assemblies constituting
our design
by combining these sub-assemblies into a
single integrated model
we can create a single integrated design
wow we can't be certain of course but i
think rube goldberg would approve
now in all of our previous projects this
is the point where i'd say
detailed step-by-step instructions for
the build are provided in your course
guide but for this project i'm not going
to say that
the greatest joy in this sort of project
lies in the exercise of
unconstrained creativity i won't deny
you that joy by providing you with my
design
we've come a long way together over
these past 24 lectures
but now it's time for you to fly solo
but in the hope that it might inspire
your efforts
here's my machine freshly arrived from
the maker space
ready for testing now when i set this
beast in motion
things are going to start happening very
quickly
so let's first take a minute to review
what's supposed to happen
i'll start the show by cutting this wire
releasing
the spring-loaded lever that will pull
the stopper from the end of the waterjet
outlet tube
the jet will strike our wheeled cart
driving it off the end of the suspension
bridge to nowhere as the cart
falls it will pull this retainer pin
release
on the rocket pendulum which will swing
through a wide arc
remaining aerodynamically stable all the
while and then knocking the golf ball
into this inclined trough
a beam that will convey the ball to this
vertical guideway
at the bottom of the guideway the
falling ball will strike the trebuchet
trigger
releasing the counterweight to fall onto
the actuator of our hydraulic system
fluid pressure will then force the
hydraulic ram forward
pushing the balloon string off of its
metal hook
the rising balloon will cause this
copper disk
to close our electrical circuit which is
powered by my desktop power supply
when the motor starts the spinning
propeller will create an air stream
that will cause the sail to generate
aerodynamic lift
this force will rotate the boom through
45 degrees
and the driven gear through 180 degrees
this ladder rotation will first pull and
then release the string
which is routed through a pulley to the
mouse clicker
this device uses a bell crank to press
the mouse button downward
and a torsion spring to release it like
this
finally you'll note that the focus of
all this mechanical effort
the computer mouse is connected to my
laptop
and on screen the mouse cursor is
positioned on the play button
of a digital media player
thus if our machine works properly it
will play a video
which i hope will serve as a suitable
finale for our course
so what's the video well it's a
collection of
outtakes from the filming of this course
now if you've seen my previous great
courses lecture series then you know
this isn't a new idea
our very imaginative producer mr james
blanford
incorporated outtakes into the final
credits of both
greek and roman technology and everyday
engineering
but for those courses the outtakes were
just for fun
here they're integral to the broader
message i hope you'll take away from
this
course for the past 24 lectures
you've been seeing lots of successes
designs that came together smoothly
demonstrations that worked
more or less as intended fabrication and
assembly tasks
completed just as planned and prototypes
that
always met the design requirements
realistically
that's all we could show you because we
simply didn't have
time to include a more complete picture
of these projects
and lectures but the outtakes video will
demonstrate that
behind the scenes things didn't always
go so smoothly
nor does engineering design ever go so
smoothly
the real world of diy engineering is a
messy place
immensely rewarding yes but also all too
often characterized by
missteps false starts dead ends
unexpected events and just plain
mistakes now what i hope to show you
through this video
is that frustrating as they might be
failures are
integral to diy engineering through our
failures
we learn how to succeed and more often
than not our failures can be
almost as much fun as our successes
and on that note let's bring our tribute
to rube goldberg
and this diy engineering adventure
to a close
[Music]
so
[Music]
this my friends is rotary wing flight
diy style
that spasms
[Music]
what our creation lacks in aerodynamic
sophistication
it makes up for in durability
and it does not because one of the
batteries is out of the holder
but now that the batteries are in place
it still doesn't run
i don't know why ah and now that the
battery's in place
it does run i think we probably need to
redo that
and a new equilibrium
and now we'll give it a try and now
we'll try it again
i mean he is not going to hurt you if
you get hit
steve tells me let's see if we can do it
our
sorry at this point a concept is
sufficiently well developed
try again sorry this is
[Music]
[Music]
now with that while this frame
might be able to carry some gravity load
represented by my two weights
i'm gonna try this again but before
leaving this preliminary phase of
testing and heading for the great
outdoors
let's consider i'm sorry i need to turn
off the fan
this propulsion and control system isn't
oh wait i gotta turn that dart thing
[Music]
okay ready
[Music]
okay ready close
ready
could somebody get me a bigger target
what's different
[Music]
now let me do a quick trial and try to
figure out what the
right position is the pivot also
incorporates a gauge
showing the angle of attack in degrees
now let's try that again
we have a problem so so when i when i
dropped it before it broke off
a portion of this lid now
now
let's try that again uh okay cool
great good my standards are getting
lower by the minute so it's fine
[Music]
and we have a failure of the switch
the very characteristic that made
innovative engineers like pierre luigi
nervy
uh i'm sorry
feeling good about this one
[Music]
what
i shouldn't have felt good about that
one
big spider crawling up on me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
success not gonna get better than that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah that was amazing
is that it yeah that's it good all right
let's wrap up
[Music]
you